tragic new numbers on the pandemic and
the heartbreaking human toll yesterday
the united states had the single
deadliest day
since this pandemic began more than 3
100 americans died
from the coronavirus now that shatters a
previous single day record and that was
set back in april
hospitalizations are also at a record
high above 100
000 nationwide up to 180 000
more americans could die in the next
eight weeks
without more precautions according to
the head of the cdc
dr robert redfield warns this winter
will be the most difficult public health
battle
in u.s history local officials are split
on how best to respond
our lead national correspondent david
begno is following this david let's
start in los angeles
which is reintroducing strict
stay-at-home orders
yeah look anthony a lot of people got a
text message alert telling them to stay
at home and some people were confused
and
it almost sounded like lock yourself
inside and don't come out
it is a very strict order new guidelines
issued last night by the mayor
who says he will vigorously enforce this
order
but there's a long list of exceptions
watch
my message couldn't be simpler it's time
to hunker down
with more los angeles residents infected
with coronavirus than ever before
mayor eric garcetti issued what's called
a targeted safer at home order
for everyone in the city directing them
to remain
in their homes it's time to cancel
everything
and if it isn't essential don't do it
now listen there are tons of exemptions
not only for essential workers but also
for those who need to keep non-essential
businesses running
including retail stores and restaurants
also exempt from the order are
faith-based services
and protests now the number of
californians hospitalized with covet 19
hit a record high for the fourth
straight day
on wednesday this is as hospitals around
the country are bracing for
a surge upon a surge as it's called
because of holiday gatherings recently
december and january and february
are going to be rough times i actually
believe they're going to be the most
difficult
time in the public health history of
this nation and those concerns have some
people pressuring the fda to
move faster on approving a vaccine but
commissioner stephen hahn told cbs news
his agency will not
cut any corners what we're going to do
is actually crunch the numbers
ourselves look at safety look at
efficacy
and we're going to do that line by line
after approval
operation warp speed hopes to have the
pfizer vaccine
out the door by december 15th with doses
allocated to states by population
for example some three hundred thousand
california one hundred and seventy
thousand in new york
nineteen thousand minnesota and twelve
thousand to maine
among the first people to get the
vaccine are frontline health workers
like dr
kurt poppenfuss he is the only full-time
doctor treating about
900 people in cheyenne wells colorado
so when he contracted the coronavirus in
late october
his hospital had to scramble to replace
him from the clinic doc
i'm the er doc and i'm the hospitalist
when i'm on call
you know i do everything i get the sense
that even though you are recovering and
you should be in bed resting you
probably feel a sense of guilt
yeah it's almost like survivor's guilt
in a way i guess it took
five different doctors to cover me in
one week if all your healthcare doctor
like me
then what the hell are you gonna do
talk about a doctor in demand listen the
good doctor was telling us that he feels
a real brain fog right now almost like
he's
kind of drunk and what they told him was
you will not be able to go back to work
until we can do a test of your cognition
skills
tony he is still getting up to speed
with the long term effects
of having had the coronavirus very
troubling david thank you very much